it's good to be back at this college uh
the last time I came here actually my
wife who couldn't be here tonight I did
pick up a research assistant who's now
doing great work for her as a Hillsdale
student and so I'm hopeful with a number
of students in the audience that uh that
I might pick up some interns or future
hires tonight as well I've already been
talking to a few prospective candidates
I was sitting next to Emily who asked me
what my favorite state was was it Ohio
where I'm from and I said I was a good
State I can't say it's the best state
she said I can tell you what's the best
state it's Indiana where she's from
so it's the cussedness of the Hillsdale
student but uh
the uh the funny story so Dr Arn
mentions my dad coming to this country
I'm sitting next to Emily who's from
Fort Wayne Indiana I'll tell you a funny
story about my father who first came to
this country to Cincinnati Ohio and I
asked him why did you come Halfway
Around the World to Cincinnati of Ohio
of all places and he says that it was
because his older sister
had actually settled in Fort Wayne
Indiana and he had to find a place that
was close to her which of course begged
the question of why his older sister
came Halfway Around the World to Fort
Wayne Indiana maybe it's because it's
the best state but the family joke is
it's the only U.S state with the word
India contained in the name of the state
so uh
Emily reminded me of that story uh
so you know actually a lot of what I'm
going to talk about tonight picks up
where Dr Arn left off which was
why my parents came to this country
the answer to that question relates to
who we are as a people and it turns out
it's not a geographic space that we all
roam as a different colored group of
higher mammals doing what iPhones tell
us to do on a given day I know that's
how it looks sometimes but
it is a vision
of a nation that brought together a
divided polyglot group of people 250
years ago
and the subject of my talk today is
going to be
the national identity crisis that we're
going through today
I'm 37 years old I was born in 1985 I
speak as a member of my generation
when I say that we today are hungry
for a purpose
My Generation we are hungry for a Cause
we're hungry for identity
at a moment in our national history when
the things that used to give us
that sense of purpose
faith
patriotism
hard work
family
those things have disappeared they have
receded in modern American Life
and we suffer from depression
and anxiety and a mental health epidemic
as we flail from one secular religion to
another from transgenderism to climatism
to covetism
just as part of our deeper search for
meaning
even as we cannot quite answer the
question of
what it even means to be an American
in the year 2023
what does it mean
to be American today I think we lack an
answer to that question
our lack of an answer to that question
is the black hole
at the center of our nation's soul
and when you have a vacuum that runs
that deep
that is when poison begins to fill the
void
that's gonna be the subject of my next
half hour
taking a stab at the answer of what it
does mean to be an American
in the year 2023
I'll take you back to the moment in
1993.
when I was in second grade in Evendale
Elementary in Southwest Ohio
when I heard Martin Luther King's I Have
a Dream speech for the first time
that was the speech where he said
I hope my four children grow up in a
country where they are judged not on the
color of their skin
but on the content of their character
I'll tell you that dream it stuck with
me
it meant something to me
because it was the dream that allowed my
dad to come to this country over 40
years ago and build a successful career
for himself at the GE plant in Evendale
Ohio despite the fact that he had a
thick Indian accent he still does to
this day
it was the dream that allowed me to go
in a single generation
from being the kid of Indian immigrants
who came to this country with almost no
money
to becoming the founder of a
multi-billion dollar biotech company I
had the privilege of leading that
company as a CEO for seven years
we worked on a number of medicines for
patients five of them are FDA approved
drugs today the one I'm personally most
proud of is an approved drug for
prostate cancer
but I stepped down as CEO of that
company
several years ago
to focus on a different kind of cancer
not a biological cancer but a cultural
cancer
that threatened to kill that dream that
Martin Luther King had 60 years ago
that threatened to kill the dream that
allowed me to achieve everything I ever
had in my life
and that is this new secular religion in
America
whose belief system centers on the idea
that your identity is based on your race
your gender and your sexual orientation
full stop
says that America is a systemically
racist country that if you're black
you're inherently disadvantaged
that if you're white you're inherently
privileged no matter your economic
background or upbringing
you're racing your gender govern who you
are and what you can achieve in life and
even what you can say even what you can
think
it's a really clever statement of this
new philosophy from congresswoman Ayanna
Presley of the squad I'm grateful to her
for articulating it so succinctly when
she said that we
do not want any more black faces that do
not want to be a black voice that we
don't want any more Brown faces that
don't want to be a brown voice end quote
I do not fit her description of what
counts as a brown voice no doubt but
there's a really clever move embedded in
there
and it's this if your race goes from
being about the color of your skin
to being about the content of the ideas
you're allowed to espouse
then any disagreement with those ideas
automatically makes you
a racist
and there is no greater damnation in
modern America than to be called a
racist or the equivalent of a racist in
our social hierarchy climate denier
bigot homophobe so on
and so when given the choice between
pledging Allegiance
to this new religion and being tarred
with the Scarlet r
everyday Americans are choosing to bend
the knee and that is what's created this
new Culture of Fear in our country
fear of losing your jobs
fear of your kids getting a bad grade in
School
fear of becoming a pariah in your own
community and that Culture of Fear
is what's replaced our culture of free
speech in America
and if you ask me
the best measure of the health of any
democracy especially American democracy
it isn't the number of ballots that get
cast every November that's just
fetishizing the final act at the end of
the process it is the percentage of
people
who feel free to say what they actually
think in public
and right now we are doing abysmally
on that metric
now in order to know where you want to
go you have to know what got you to
where you are
and part of the story of what got us
here actually began through none other
than
a perversion
of capitalism itself dating back to the
2008 financial crisis on the back of the
bailouts and the wake of the 2008
financial crisis something really
interesting happened in this country
it's not just that Barack Obama was
elected president though that was part
of it
in the wake of the bailouts there was a
grand bargain in this country an
unspoken Grand bargain between big
business and what used to be our
conception of big government it went
like this okay
if you're going to get that public money
to save the bankers when times go bad
but you made a lot of money when times
went good then the Occupy Wall Street
movement has a claim on that wealth well
the Occupy Wall Street movement said is
we're going to take that money from
those wealthy corporate fat cats and
redistribute it to poor people to help
poor people
but right around that time there was a
new birth of progressivism in this
country that had a different theory of
the case what they had to say was
you know what the real problem wasn't
quite just economic Injustice
wasn't quite just poverty no it was
racial Injustice
and misogyny and bigotry and climate
change
and that actually presented a lifeline
to big business in this country
because if you're Wall Street you don't
like Occupy Wall Street very much but
the new woke stuff is actually pretty
easy you applaud diversity and inclusion
put some token minorities on your boards
you Muse about the racially disparate
impact of climate change after you fly
in that private jet to Davos
it's pretty good work if you can get it
but they didn't do it for free
there was an implicit ask in return
that the new Left looked the other way
when it came to leaving their corporate
power intact and it worked so well for
Wall Street that Silicon Valley didn't
get in on the ACT what Silicon Valley
realized was that the old version of
breakup big Tech used to come from the
left well here's what we can do
we will use our Monopoly power to
advance your ideas we will use our
Monopoly power to take down hate speech
or misinformation as you define it but
we will not do it for free
we expect the new Progressive Movement
to look the other way
when it comes to leaving hour
Monopoly power intact
that is the story of this arranged
marriage
it is not an arranged marriage of love
it is more like Mutual prostitution
and the net result of that act is the
birth of this new
ESG industrial woke industrial complex
that's actually a new hybrid of state
power and corporate power that's far
more powerful than either one alone and
when you get that much power
concentrated in the way that it is state
power and corporate power combined then
it lends itself to capture
and that's what happened in more recent
years when a new actor showed up on the
scene
and turned that arranged marriage
into a three-party affair
that is the Communist Party of China
they understand this game far more
deeply than any of us do what they
realized is okay now we can take this
one step further if we can get those
same companies
that will critique the United States
relentlessly that will apply emissions
caps over there in their apologist model
of capitalism
to do business in China without saying a
peep about the actual human rights
atrocities over here we have undermined
America's greatest geopolitical asset of
all and that is not our nuclear Arsenal
it is our moral standing
on the global stage
that's how you get Disney who two years
ago will say can't shoot a film in the
state of Georgia if Georgia passes an
anti-abortion statute that says it
cannot Abide a new law in Florida that
prevents Public School teachers from
teaching six-year-olds about
transgenderism and gender identity but
will go in the same period to film Mulan
in the shinjang province of China
literally Ground Zero of the uyghur
human rights crisis where there are over
1 million religious minorities enslaved
in concentration camps
subject to forced sterilization
communist indoctrination and worse
without saying a peep
until the very end of the movie you
could still see it in the credits today
where they say we thank the local
authorities for allowing us the
privilege of filming here
reminds me of those trees in Harlem
that was what Disney got out of that
trade
but it turns out every other company is
doing the same thing Nike BlackRock
Airbnb JP Morgan Chase the NBA why do
they do it
the answer is actually really simple
it comes down to money
because if you're the CCP you build a
great Chinese wall that prevents you
from entering the Chinese market
if you criticize the CCP but if you
criticize the United States or hamstring
its economy with those emissions caps we
will roll out the red carpet and so
companies do what companies do that is
why Tim Cook and Larry Fink are XI
jinping's circus monkeys
he will say jump
they will say how high because it comes
down to their bottom line
it is the direct product of a bipartisan
consensus in this country back in the
1990s
conviction in the faith of democratic
capitalism
the idea that somehow we could use
capitalism as a vehicle to spread
democracy to places like China
the idea that we could export Big Macs
and happy meals and somehow that was
going to spread freedom
well what they realized is they could
turn that game on its head
we thought we could use our money to get
them to be more like us
they realized they could use their money
access to their Market
to get us to be more like them
or even one step better than that that
they could use our money to get us to be
more like them
sending back those Disney movies and
iPhones as Trojan horses to undermine
the United States from within
so that is the problem
as I see it the concentration of state
power and corporate power that lends
itself to capture facing down a threat
far more
deep and dangerous than we've anything
we've faced in our nation's history the
Soviet Union did not supply the shoes on
our feet or the phones in our pocket
that is what makes our unique moment far
more complicated than anything I think
we faced in the latter half of the 20th
century
so where do we go from here
my first view is that not against not
all solutions
will be delivered
or ought to be delivered through
politics
I think that market actors
can play a role
part of the concentration of power
starts with the inappropriate government
coordinated concentration of capital the
three largest financial institutions and
asset managers in this country
are BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
three institutions who together manage
about 20 trillion dollars that is about
as much money as the United States GDP
in three hands the largest aggregation
of capital in private hands in human
history certainly in American history
and yet all of those firms are using
that money with due respect probably
including money of most of you in this
room
to vote for racial Equity audits at
companies like apple or scope 3
emissions caps at companies like Chevron
implementing political and social
agendas that nobody voted for using the
money of everyday citizens to advance
one-sided agendas that most of those
everyday citizens actually disagree with
actually there's really funny twist in
this story BlackRock is actually the
firm that causes firms like Exxon and
Chevron to drop oil production projects
here at home you might wonder if this
might actually serve as at least one
small step forward in the March against
global climate change
even then you'd be wrong because it
turns out many of those same projects
are still proceeding
only under different ownership
under the ownership of the likes of
petrochina
who's buying up the very projects that
Chevron is dropping and then you look up
who's one of the largest foreign
shareholders of petrochina
and it's actually none other than
BlackRock using Chinese Citizens Capital
to own that company instead that's how
deep this problem runs but Market actors
can make a difference
this is why I found its strive a little
over a year ago to compete with
BlackRock State Street in Vanguard using
shareholder power the money of everyday
citizens to deliver a different message
to Corporate America to tell companies
to focus exclusively on Excellence over
Politics on making excellent products
and services for your customers without
apology and yes making money in the
process maximizing value for your
shareholders without apology
and to dilute the power the exercised by
this small handful of actors we're about
a year into this I'll tell you that when
JP Morgan Chase got into the exchange
traded funds business it took them over
a year over two years actually to cross
a billion dollars in assets under
management we crossed 500 million half a
billion in our first three months I hope
that this is just the beginning of a
bottom-up revolution I remember when we
talked about this the last time I came
here we hadn't even gotten started Dr
Arnon we're well on our way to hopefully
driving that change through the
corporate sector
but Market Solutions alone are not going
to be enough to spawn the national
Revival that we need I think we need an
Awakening of a new conservative movement
a new American movement in this country
that answers that question that our
generation Longs for what does it mean
to be an American
in the year 2023.
our inner animal spirit
has been domesticated it has been Tamed
by this new culture
that rejects truth and Embraces
relativism
that rejects God and Embraces secularism
that rejects democracy and Embraces
aristocracy
that rejects free speech and Embraces
censorship that rejects equality of
opportunity and Embraces Equity of
results that rejects excellence
and Embraces victimhood
that inner animal that has left oceans
to lift up countries like China on the
other side of the world while their
culture of maoist victimhood has left
oceans in the other directions to hold
us back
you know what I say when we rallied many
of us did behind the cry to make America
great again
I don't think we hungered for a single
man
I think we hungered for the Unapologetic
pursuit of excellence in our country
thank you
this is deeply personal
to me
I told you about my parents they came
here in the late 70s and early 80s
respectively I was born in the mid 80s
had I been born 20 years earlier in this
country
I don't think my story would have been
possible not in the same way
but what worries me is that had I been
born 20 years later
I'm not sure my story would have been
possible either
you see to me the American dream it's
not just about going from being
middle class or not rich
to making a lot of money
the American dream is about
a conviction in your agency as an
individual
a belief that you are more than the
tectonic plates of group identity that
move you the genetics that brought you
into this world a conviction in your
purpose as a citizen that is really what
the American dream means to me
and for me as a kid who grew up with the
funny last name nerdy glasses skinny kid
with a dad who had a funny accent in
Southwest Ohio when I grew up Merit and
achievement was our ticket ahead
you know what if you're going to thank
you very much if you're going to be that
kid who stands out from the group you
might as well be outstanding
that's what my parents taught me okay
to get ahead through hard work that
hardship is not the same thing as
victimhood that there is more to life
than self-indulgence that in today's
terms there's more to life and there's a
greater Point than figuring out your
gender there are things to do things to
be accomplished in the world we have
much to do in the short time we have
been given that is the American dream
those are the values that brought my
parents to this country and that they
instilled in us today
we should want more people like that
entering this country
we would do well to restore meritocracy
in who gets into this country
thank you
my parents they worked hard
they paid their taxes they followed the
rules
they raised two kids who went on to
found companies that employed thousands
of people and improved the lives of
thousands of Americans
that is a good thing
they made sacrifices to raise a family
through their example taught us that
there is more to leadership than just
following your latest whim that you have
to make a sacrifice to be in a marriage
that you have to make a sacrifice to be
a father and a mother but that those
sacrifices are worth making because it
is in service of something greater than
yourself
those are the immigrants we want rather
than
people whose First Act of entering this
country is by definition a law breaking
one
I think we need I speak as a first
generation American when I say this we
need to secure that border
unapologetically and restore meritocracy
over lawlessness in determining not only
who gets into America
but then who gets ahead
in America
Revive Our conviction thank you
that Martin Luther King was right
that you get ahead in America not on the
color of your skin but on the content of
your character and your contributions
it's going to say something that's going
to be very difficult for a lot of people
to swallow but that means that when the
Supreme Court
overturns affirmative action in college
admissions as I hope and expect they
will later this year
every College in the country may follow
the Hillsdale way
but not just every College in the
country every institution in this
country
moving beyond the de facto racism that
has defined
our hiring practices our Merit practices
in the private sector and in every other
sphere of American life now a lot of
people don't know this affirmative
action actually started it's spread in
America
with the actions of the federal
government itself where most bad things
often begin
there was a Johnson era executive order
and not a lot of people know this
it's it's been a National Cancer on our
soul
under Lyndon Johnson an executive orders
11246 what it says is
that if you're doing business with the
federal government if you're a
government contractor that might sound
like a side category no it's over 20
percent of the US Workforce from Boeing
to Google are encompassed by this
executive order if you do any business
with the government
you have to adopt racial quota systems
in your hiring practices
with three Republican presidents since
who could have rescinded that with a
stroke of a pen they each chose not to
because of the fear of political
backlash I think there's an opportunity
in this country to not only overturn
affirmative action in college admissions
but to eradicate it in every sphere of
Our Lives starting with the actions and
the example of the federal government
itself
it's not just Merit in who gets in and
who gets ahead but even meritocracy in
government itself
this is not a republican idea or a
Democratic idea but I have a I have my
own dream as an American
that the people who we elect to run the
government
are actually the people
who run the government
thank you
may seem like that's not a lot to ask
but that's not the case today
right the next time you have an
unelected bureaucrat like Anthony fauci
or Merrick Garland or James Comey for
that matter who wishes to exercise
political power that no one elected them
to exercise you need Chief Executives at
the federal level and at the state level
who will do what they're
constitutionally empowered to do
to fire them
to fire the legions of people under them
to fire the managerial industrial
complex around them because you know
what if somebody works for you and you
can't fire them
that means they don't work for you it
means you work for them it means you are
their slave because you are accountable
for what their what they do without
having any responsibility for what they
do they will say that they have Civil
Service Protections in this country
well I personally view those as
unconstitutional because Article 2 of
The Constitution is higher
in the hierarchy of our nation's laws
than any law that Congress passed but
even if it were true that we have these
Civil Service protections
it's got to be the top of a new
conservative movement a new pro-american
movement's agenda in this country to
repeal those Civil Service protections
and if you ask me replace them
with sunset Clauses instead
to say that if you can't be a federal
employee as the President of the United
States for more than eight years
that you probably shouldn't be an
employee
of the federal government for more than
eight years no matter what position that
you're serving in and bring that fresh
lifeblood not just into our country but
into our federal government
[Applause]
now
one of the areas where I care about
meritocracy is not just who rules in
government but the ideas that Prevail in
our society and in our government too
and we can only have a meritocracy of
ideas in America if we embrace one of
the foundational cornerstones of the
Great American experiment and that is
free speech
free speech is a precondition
you see it right here for the pursuit of
Truth
I personally believe that free speech is
also a precondition
for peace in America
because if you tell people
they cannot speak that is when they
scream
but you tell people they can't scream
that is when they tear things down
today we have in this country a form of
censorship that's not what a lot of
people on cable television like to call
it Big Tech censorship
I call it what it really is it is
government Tech censorship
it is the government using private
companies to do through the back door
what government could not do through the
front door under the Constitution to
censor politically disfavored speech we
need to abandon the slogans we memorized
in 1980 saying that these are private
companies free to decide what does and
doesn't show up on their website that's
true if they're behaving as private
companies but if they're doing the Dirty
Work of government if it is State action
in disguise
then the Constitution still applies and
these companies ought to be bound by the
First Amendment to the Constitution of
the United States when they're
coordinating with the government to do
what the government itself could not do
directly
thank you
but our censorship culture it's not just
limited to the internet
it extends into the workforce and into
our economy
the number of individuals in the
American Workforce who were fired for
saying the wrong thing at work
wearing the Hat of the wrong political
candidate posting the wrong thing on
social media showing up at the wrong
political rally
staggering over the last three years
what I say is that
if you can't fire somebody or
de-platform somebody on account of their
race or their sex or their sexual
orientation or their religion or their
national origin
then you should not be able to fire
somebody or de-platform somebody on
account of their political speech either
I personally believe we need to make
political expression
a civil right in this country right up
there next to the other protected
classes
thank you
now there's a 1980 version of the
conservative in me okay
that would say that these are private
businesses that we shouldn't want to
interfere that we should leave this to
the market that if these businesses over
here want to fire these great
conservatives that's an opportunity for
these other businesses to hire them
instead leave it to the market no more
regulation you know I said there's
certain logic to that
but you cannot have it both ways
okay
if you want to go back and repeal those
protected classes and Really Leave It to
the market in the year 2023 to do its
work great I'll be right there with you
but so long as we're not doing that we
have to apply these standards
even-handedly to say that if you can't
fire somebody or deplat from somebody
because they're black or gay or Muslim
or white or Christian or Jewish or Hindu
or whatever
that you should not be able to fire them
just because they're an outspoken
conservative or an outspoken liberal
either we need to apply these standards
even-handedly and I don't think we even
need to wait for legislatures to act
though for the last two years I've been
calling on them too
I think that there's
rampant breaches of existing civil
rights laws as they exist in America
already I'll give you my favorite one
so the prohibition on religious
discrimination under the Civil Rights
statutes in this country actually a lot
of people don't know this
doesn't just mean that you can't
discriminate against an employee on
account of their religion
but it also means that you as the
employer in most cases cannot force your
employee
to bow down to your religion
well that didn't just raises the simple
question of whether the modern woke
agenda Dei agenda in Corporate America
meets the Supreme Court's test for what
counts as a religion
turns out you go down the criteria the
court has laid out meets that test to a
t certain words you can't say clothes
you can't wear apologies you must recite
excommunication procedures that must be
initiated
you know secular humanism actually
counts under the Supreme Court's
standards for what counts as a religion
if that's the case the modern woke
agenda meets that test in Spades and so
the good news is I think that there are
opportunities not to just have to to
reinvent the legislative wheel but to
apply the laws that already got us as
far as we already have
and I think if we're able to do those
things
to revive the basic ideas that got us to
where we are that the people who we
elect to run the government run the
government that were free to speak
openly as long as our neighbors have the
same courtesy in return that you get
ahead in this country not on the color
of your skin but the content of your
character that you get ahead based on
Merit that we put the Merit back into
America to say that you can achieve
anything you ever want in this country
with your own hard work and commitment
and dedication and believe in that
vision of the American dream then we can
take on
the single greatest external threat that
we will face in our generation
okay we Face an enemy in communist China
that powers our modern way of life
in China There's no distinction between
economic policy and military policy they
are two sides of the same coin
now
we depend on China
we got to where we are but going forward
if we're really going to declare
independence from China
and I do think that that is what the
Declaration of Independence in 2023
calls for that's going to involve some
level of sacrifice
it's going to involve some level of
trade-off
to be able to achieve semiconductor
self-sufficiency before China invades
Taiwan while we have to protect Taiwan
vigorously to protect our own way of
life
to be able to shore up our own energy
leadership position globally by
abandoning the constraints of a new
climate religion that shackles the West
while leaving China untouched to tell
our children to lead them rather than to
be afraid of them saying that you know
what if you can't smoke an addictive
cigarette by the time you're 18 years
old you probably should not be using
addictive social media apps like Tick
Tock until you're 16 years old or later
either if at all tell businesses and
thank you
businesses in this country that you will
not do business in China until the CCP
reforms its behaviors including
abandoning its practices of intellectual
property theft U.S user data theft and
the other practices that don't make this
a capitalist game but a mercantilist one
holding communist China accountable for
the covid-19 pandemic the worst pandemic
in over a century unleashing hell on the
rest of the world using every Financial
lever we have to do it because if we
don't we can expect even worse in the
future these will not be easy things to
do
they will involve short-term sacrifices
they will involve short-term pain
but America's current moment calls
for one of your favorites for Churchill
not for Chamberlain and I believe we can
make these sacrifices we can rise to
that occasion
if we really answer that question of who
we are
As Americans
we have celebrated for the last decade
our diversity and our differences
forgetting all of the ways in which we
are really just the same
as one people
our diversity is not our strength
our strength is that which binds us
together
across our diversity
e pluribus unum
from many
one
that is the vision
that won the American Revolution 250
years ago
that is the vision that reunited us
after the Civil War
that is the vision that won US World War
one and World War II and the Cold War
that is the vision that still gives hope
to the Free World and if we can revive
those common ideals over fractious group
identity and grievance than nobody in
the world
not a nation not a corporation not a
virus is going to defeat us that is what
American exceptionalism is all about and
that is what we're going to need to
revive in order to save this great
nation thank you and I look forward to
continuing this conversation thank you
very much
thank you